hey guys compares here I'm going to show
you just a few exercises that I found
very helpful for hip and ankle mobility
or flexibility because these have been
to weak points in line for a very long
time
had a lot of injuries both in the hips
and in the ankles my dorsiflexion on the
left is terrible compared to the right
so I'll show you what I mean if I have
check this out my toes on the same line
okay and I push my knees forward you can
see that my right knee is probably good
three to four inches ahead of my left
and the left Fuels bone-on-bone
a lot of the times but I'll show you
three things that have helped with that
end with improving what you might call
grumpy baby I've never been able to do
happy baby in yoga which is effectively
what I just showed you so working on
that has been extremely important for a
number of sports I'm working on and
acrobatics and acro yoga so what to do
these were both things that resisted
many different attempts previously so
the first thing I'm going to show you is
from coach summer gymnastic bodies
former national team coach for men's
gymnastics and that is effectively and
there are many different ways to about
this but first let's just say you did
sixty calf raises okay and count it off
and then went down into a position like
this going to be diagonal okay and I'm
not going to be doing this perfectly you
notice this is kind of out to the side
to take out the hip flexor and then I'm
just stretching the Achilles and calf
here alright and then I would hold this
for sixty two hundred twenty seconds you
should all check out his programming
because it's much more sophisticated and
this is from him but that is exercise
one you would do it on both sides next
I'm going to give the ankles a bit of a
break and work on the grumpy baby a
happy baby transition and this is very
simple I'm going to be in this type of
staggered position okay my hips are
square so I'm not rotating like this or
rotating this way I'm not in a warrior
pose of any type my toes are pointing
straight ahead and this is very similar
to what you might have seen from say
ever Stegen
or aircraft see there's a lot of great
work with this type of thing I'm just
going to drop the elbow and then keeping
this leg in up pull with my back to get
a lot of rotation and just do this
perhaps six times going to max depth for
a very short half second or second you
notice that if one is reasonably easy to
do I'm going to inch that foot forward
and then you would repeat on the
opposite side same story alright and
yeah and then just like that
not spending a lot of time in these
positions that's how you end up really
really sore often times if you are
spending a lot of time in those
positions again refer to coach summer on
this you're not going to be doing
intensive long hold all the time you
might be doing it once a week twice a
week that's it all right the next move
maybe one to recovered the Achilles
stretch after engorging the area with
blood we talked about the D sort of
grumpy baby - happy baby and this one is
a Cossack squat so nothing has helped my
ankle dorsiflexion dorsiflexion pulling
the foot back right that range of motion
as much as Kasich squats and these were
really introduced to me by Pavel top
suelen who's very well known for
popularizing kettlebells in the u.s.
among other things and you can do this
without weights and you should first the
key element or one of the key elements
for the goals that we have that I
discussed is you want to keep your hips
as low as possible as you move from one
side to the other now you can do them
with your foot like so this is going to
use the adductors more or you can you
can flip this one out and get more
hamstring I tend to do it this way and
then from here you would just glide
across I have a lot of trouble keeping
my hips low to here they can already see
that this ankle is more restricted I
find because of that restriction it's
counterintuitive really perhaps easier
when you have some weight to load with
and that is true with pistols oftentimes
one-legged squats okay so if I'm here
and get this up just kind of a goblet
hold okay like so I tend to put it right
under the chin and then just coming
across like this and I'll spend a little
bit of time just working on each side a
few seconds do that six times or so drop
the kill Bell come on up relax and
that's about it
the consistency is more important than
the intensity or the volume and for more
on that for more on stretching I highly
recommend Coach summer Somm er Pavel
Tatsu and relaxing to stretch but our
starter kits go there are three that I
found very very helpful
hope you enjoyed the video if you would
like to see my favorite piece of content
that I put out every week it is a short
newsletter five bullet Friday it's free
five bullet points with the coolest
things that I've been finding using
testing in a given week I put it out
every Friday you can digest in about 5
minutes
take a look Bible of Friday